you can be as stealthy as you like but
you can't hide reality we have the
highest tax burden for 70 years
during the middle of an inflation crisis
so i asked the prime minister again why
do he and the chancellor keep raising
taxes on working people
[Music]
prime minister mr speaker what we are
doing is helping people with it with the
cost of living
cutting taxes for those on universal
credit mr speaker as i have said uh
helping people with the cost of their
fuel mr speaker with the cold weather
payments uh the warm homes payments mr
speaker doing all the things that this
country would expect lifting the living
wage which this party mr speaker
introduced this party this government
has increased by the record amount uh mr
speaker and what we and above all and
one above all the most important thing
that we are doing is helping people into
work 500 000 people off welfare into
work on under our way to work scheme
more people more people in work now than
before the pandemic began and that is
the record is coming
labour never forget mr speaker there's
never been a labour government
that left office with unemployment lower
[Applause]
[Music]
lots of words lots of bluster no answers
word of warning
word of warning prime minister that's
not going to work with the police
[Music]
[Applause]